So, da wollen wir mal das Puffe hintrauf nehmen. Ich hasse alle Menschen, die ein Instrument so halb beherrschen. Das gleiche mit Scheiss-Gitarre. Stairway to fucking bullshit heaven. Oh, okay. Dann halt so. Alle singen immer Wonder fucking Wall. Alle spielen die gleichen Kack-Songs. Ja, aber ich will da nur ein Intro machen. Tipp, wenn ihr noch irgendwen beeindrucken wollt, spielt einfach irgendeinen anderen Song. Ja. Ja, gut, dann halt so. Will und Titzer, Will und Titzer, Will und Titzer, Will und Titzer, Puffo, Puffo, Puffo, Puffo, Puffo, Puffo, Puffo, Puffo. Ja, da kannst du nichts sagen. Das ist so super geworden. Ne da kannst du nichts sagen, das war super geworden.
Nö, da kannst du nichts sagen, herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr da seid, herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Hausgabe vom Das...
Ich dachte mir, wer ist der Dritte im Bunde, wer ist der Dritte der einen ... Hab ich auch gedacht.
Theiss, Theiss, Theiss, Theiss, Theiss, Theiss, Theiss, Theiss, Theiss.
Nein, es war Flo, Flo, Flo, es war Florian. Vielen Dank für dieses tolle Intro. Schön, dass du uns Stefan Tietzes Arroganz mal wieder wirklich in Reinform vorgeführt hast. Oh, ich habe es ganz anders interpretiert. Ich habe es als Heilsbringertum St. Stefan interpretiert. Ja, okay. Aber das passt ja ein bisschen dazu, was du gerade gesagt hast. Aber ich denke mir, ja, wenn jetzt alle aufhören würden, Stairway to Heaven und Wonderwall zu spielen, dann wäre die Welt schöner. Und ich möchte den Rant sogar noch erweitern, bei Leuten wie du, die dann so die Mondscheinsonate lernen und dann sie immer an jedes Klavier setzen, was überall auch stehen könnte. Und dann hauen sie entweder Amélie, Mondscheinsonate oder Riverflow's Inu raus. Oder er Fabel-Cotino-Nuitreté, die Fabelhefte der Welt der Amélie. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Und dann Debussy, Debussy auch noch gerne rausgeholt. Ja, das war wirklich sehr schwer. Chopin wird rausgeholt. Chopin, Chopin, ja, es stimmt schon, du hast recht, Musik ist eine schwierige Sache. Originalität. Wie heisst du denn überhaupt? Hm? Wie heisst du denn überhaupt? Ich jetzt? Ja. Stell dich mal vor, bitte, den Hörerinnen und Hörern. Stefan, jetzt komm. Bei dem ganzen Ranten und auf andere gucken, habe ich ganz vergessen, wer ich eigentlich selber bin. Wer ist nun eigentlich selber? Mein Name ist Stefan, das Fandische für Spaß, wir sitzen hier und begeben Gas. Du bist in einem Rap-Loop gefangen, sein ganzes Leben lang. Du auch! Salz, Pfeffer, Pfeffer, Salz. Oh, das sind ganz alte Referenzen. Aber ja, ich bin nicht gut im Freestyle, muss man sagen. Ich habe aber letztens wirklich mal die Probe aufs Exempel gemacht und mir gedacht, Beatbox, ich habe kein gutes Bild von Beatboxen, ich verachte Beatbox, ist mittlerweile öffentlich, die Beatbox-Szene schaut mit Verachtung und feuchten Händen auf mich herunter, aber das ist in Ordnung, weil sie in ihre Hände spucken bei Beatboxen und deswegen dachte ich, manche Personengruppen können mich gerne verachten, da habe ich gar nichts dagegen, also wenn jetzt wirklich der internationale Bund der Jongleure ein Statement raussetzt und sich von mir distanziert, sage ich überhaupt kein Problem. Bist du
komplett bescheuert? Kommt doch,
kommt doch. Weißt du, womit Jongleure jonglieren?
Kommt doch. Fackeln, Messer?
Ja, Kettensägen, aber nur noch
oben, ich bin ja weit weg, die können
ihr entwerfen. Du bist unten, Flachwesen,
Flotel ist ein Flachwesen, Flotel ist unten am Boden.
Ich lege mich unter die, da können die mir gar nichts.
Und genauso habe ich vergrätzt
den Internationalen Bund der Beatboxer
und ich habe aber tatsächlich die Probe aufs
Exemple gemacht, habe ich gesagt, tue ich dir nicht unrecht
Und ich habe ich vergrätzt den Internationalen Bund der Beatboxer. Und ich habe aber tatsächlich die Probe aufs Exemple gemacht, habe ich gesagt, tue ich dir nicht unrecht. Und ich habe wirklich mal mich zu Hause hingesetzt und habe gesagt, so, jetzt höre ich mir mal wirklich eine Stunde lang Beatbox an. Einfach mal Best of Beatbox auf YouTube. Und es war absolut unerträglich. Guantanamo Bay-eske Zustände in meinem Zimmer sind entstanden, Musikfolter. Mir wurde ein Video in die Timeline gespült und das war extrem beeindruckend, aber auch kurz. So, es ist beeindruckend, aber beeindruckend ist was anderes als Genuss. Du kannst sehr beeindruckt sein von etwas, aber das Problem mit beeindruckt sein ist, man ist kurz beeindruckt, aber es hört sofort wieder auf. Man denkt sich, wow, Blue Man Group, krass, die machen Musik mit Tonnen, wow, das ist ja cool. Die sind blau. Warum war der Fakt, dass die blau waren in dieser Beschreibung? Hat die noch nicht mal erwähnt. Aber wirklich, in dem Moment, in dem ich mir meiner Bewunderung bewusst werde, sage ich, was gibt es sonst noch so? Kann man sonst noch irgendwas anderes sagen? Schatz, wie lange ist die Show? Wie lange ist die Show? Die dauert zweieinhalb Stunden. Pst, was? Einfach, was? Das ist es jetzt?
Ja, weil die dann auch zweieinhalb Stunden auf so Mülltonnen rumtrommeln.
Ja, und ich glaube, so ist jonglierend für mich auch. Wow, krass, der kann die werfen, können wir sonst irgendwas anderes machen?
Aber wirklich in der Geschwindigkeit, sofort weiter.
Nee, aber die wissen es ja genau, dann zu überraschen.
Ja, das stimmt. Also dann kommen zum Beispiel die Bälle von außen. Oder da kommt die Hand und dann machen sie Tricks, plötzlich haben sie einen Ball in der Hand und man denkt, hä, wie geht das denn? Wer joggt Bälle, wenn der eine Hand einfach einen Ball in der Hand hält und dann so durch die anderen Bälle bewegt? Ja, ja, ja. Also die wissen immer, wenn man so denkt, so jetzt habe ich es gesehen, dann kommt ein neuer Trick und man ist wieder beeindruckt. Ich merke, du hast keine Faszination für Zirki. Zirken ist für mich tatsächlich überhaupt gar kein Ort. Aber generell auch nicht zu beeindrucken. Da sind wir da, das ist ein Punkt, an dem wir ganz anders sind. Ich bin sehr leicht zu beeindrucken und auch sehr begeisterungsfähig. Und deswegen so Beatboxing, du hast recht, es ist nicht etwas anderes als irgendwie Genuss. Ich merke das auch, weil ich kann zum Beispiel sehr laut klatschen. Und selbst in Situationen, wo man klatschen soll, wie im Theater oder so, oder so, wie in der Filharmonie-Shit, drehen sich Leute dann recht schnell auch um nach mir. Und dem merkt man auch, ah, sie finden es irgendwie beeindruckend, dass ich so laut klatschen kann, aber dann kippt es sehr schnell in, so. Ja, ja. Ich wurde mal ermahnt beim Klatschen, leiser zu klatschen. Wirklich, der Dirigent macht dann so bei dir die Posaune etwas lauter, Stefan Tietze in der zweiten Reihe etwas leiser. Ja, und der andere wohingegen, Oma Erna hinten ein bisschen lauter, bisschen lauter, da kommt gar nichts, schläft, Oma Erna schläft. Ja, ich habe ein Video gesehen von so einer Abschlussklasse, in den USA gibt es ja immer so diese, da werden dann die Urkunden überreicht mit diesen Hüten, Tellerhüten, eine Kultur so fremd, dass man gar nicht anfängt zu versuchen, es zu verstehen. Du ungebildeter Fazke. Ich hatte ein Vier gegen Hut und dann wird, wenn man graduated, wurde mir sogar der Bommel von links nach rechts oder von rechts, links weiß ich nicht mehr, gelegt. Du hast in Good Old, in Nordrhein-Westfalen mit einem Vier-Ex-Quadrathut promoviert. Ja, hab den so eine Union aufgeschmissen und dann aber natürlich wieder eingesammelt, wie so ein Idiot welchen haben wollte und dann weggeworfen, nach ein paar Jahren weggeworfen. Hast du während er in der Luft war geguckt, wo deiner lag? Ja, ja, ja. Also du konntest im Moment gar nicht genießen im Sinne von Freiheit, sondern du warst, ah okay, warte, ich hab den nur geliehen. Das ist ein typischer Moment, der, wenn man den weiterlaufen lässt, in Filmen, ich glaube, das ist immer so. Ja, ja, genau. Alle werfen das hoch und das ist aber der Punkt, wo der oft Freeze frame oder so oder ihr fragt euch sicherlich, wie ich da hingekommen bin. Genau, ja, ihr fragt euch sicherlich, was mit all diesen Hüten nach der Zeremonie passiert ist. Aber was dann passiert, direkt nach dem Schwenk der Kamera in die Luft, wo die alle hochfliegen ist, alle wieseln rum und suchen sich ihren, hast du, da mischt die Rebecca drin, Rebecca, Rebecca, Rebecca, Rebecca R.
Schon am Buffet.
Aber das ist so ein bisschen ähnlich wie ein Mittelalterfilm mit Bogenschützen oder Legolas in Herr der Ringe.
Mega cool.
Wir haben lange nicht mehr drüber gesprochen. Love it.
Richtig cool, Metzeln alle nieder, Uruk-Kai, was ja eine Mischung ist aus Orks und Bilbismenschen.
Korrekt. Und dann ist die Schlacht vorbei und dann so, oh. Aber ich weiß nicht, was Bilbismenschen sind. Ich finde es gut zu sagen, dass es eine Kreuzung ist aus Orks und Bilbismenschen. Genau, ja. Aber ich weiß, was Bilbismenschen sind, nein. Auch hier, Beeindruckendheit kann betäuben. Man ist so beeindruckt von dem Wort Bilvis, dass niemand sagt, Moment, der weiss nicht ein Millimeter mehr als das, sondern dabei bestehen. So funktionieren wir beide. Ja. Betäuben durch punktuelles Wissen. Genau, durch kurzes, wirklich betäuben, kurzes intellektuelles Beinstellen. Kurz den Teppich unter den Füssen wegziehen und dann ganz schnell das Thema wechseln. Das ist das, was Hypnotiseure machen, bevor sie Leute so verwirren. Genau. Drei Punkte und dann so drei Presspunkte im Körper und dann so, und dann du fällst in tiefen Schlaf. Das machen wir mit Wissen. Genau. Und da denke ich mir auch immer, wenn es dann heißt, Sie haben Marion Pippin hinterher und Legolas so, gib mir einen Moment, bitte, gib mir einen Moment, ich muss kurz meine Pfeile aufsammeln. Es ist schneller, Leute, es ist schneller, wenn wir alle helfen. Ich such deine Pfeile nicht, Elb! Es ist schneller, Gimli, es ist wirklich, wir kommen schneller voran, wenn jeder zusammenhilft. Dann musst du auch meine Axt suchen und dann wirft er so die Axt weg. Okay, ich suche alleine. Und dann sieht man einfach nur, wie der in so einem Gebüsch so... Ja. Ich komme nicht ganz hin, ich komme nicht ganz hin, auf, auf, auf, und ein Pfeil hängt so im Baum und er guckt so und versucht zu rütteln und denkt sich, warte, ich schiesse den runter mit einem anderen Pfeil. Und dann hängt der zweite Pfeil auch noch im Baum und dann, ah verdammt, ähm, Boromir, ah, ah und so. Und das aber jedes Mal, nach jedem Kampf, zehn Minuten unerträgliche, witzige, aber unnötige Szenen. Aber jetzt frage ich natürlich, ich weiss ja, dass du da eine unangenehme Begeisterung pflegst für Krieg und Kriegereien und Tod und so. Du hast ja so eine sehr martialische Ader in dir. Ja. Deswegen die Frage, wie war es denn im Mittelalter? Haben die danach am Ende die Pfeile eingesammelt? Und waren alle Pfeile auch mit den gegnerischen Bögen kompatibel? Also hatten die immer eine gleich dicke Sehne? Deswegen hast du ja die Pfeile extra so gebaut, dass der Gegner sie nicht benutzen kann. Du hattest ja die Kreuz- und die Schlitzbögen. Ja. Das heisst, die Kreuzbögen können keine Schlitzschiessen. Das heisst, wenn du, weil das Problem ist ja, du schiessst, sagen wir mal bei der schiessst bei einer Belagerung den Pfeil in die Burg und die denken sich, danke für den Pfeil, du Vollidiot! Und dann, ah, jetzt gibt man denen den Pfeil, weil man will ja eigentlich aushungern, jetzt haben die einen Pfeil mehr. Deswegen musst du die anders hinten an der Nocke, Kreuzziel ist wie Völkerball, hinten die Nocke der Pfeile, da wo du die Sehne einhängst. Und jetzt habe ich kein Interesse mehr. Jetzt ist es wie Beatboxen für mich. Jetzt ist es so ein Rauschen. Man unterschätzt aber öfter, wie extrem, was für ein extremer logistischer Aufwand Pfeile im Mittelalter waren. Also du musst dir ja vorstellen, wie ich bei so grossen Schlachten mit grossen Armeen mit Bogenschützen, wie du wirklich Wagenladungen an Pfeilen brauchst. Also viele, viele Pferde dicht bepackt mit Pfeilen, das ich gerne mal in einem Film sehen würde. Weil oft haben die Leute ja nur das, was sie am Körper tragen und du siehst keinen Tross oder irgendwas in der Geschichte. Nein, Tross. Aber dass du einfach mal siehst, dann einfach noch so acht. Das ist ja auch ein spannendes Spin-off. Also ich finde es spannender als die jährige Serie. So heißt auch der Film Tross, Tross und einfach so die Schlacht hinten, du siehst so Pfeile fliegen am Horizont und da ist so, okay, also wir haben jetzt noch sechstausend Fässer Met, haben wir noch Wasser, müssen wir zum Fluss, ist dieser Fluss krank oder nicht oder gibt's eine Krankheit? Weiß ich nicht. Wie kann dich das nicht interessieren? Nein, ich bin einfach so müde. Du bist Versorgung, bist auch versorgen. Ja, aber wir müssen die Leute versorgen. Wir laufen, wir laufen denen hinterher und die haben ihre Schritte beschleunigt. Legos hat in den Boden gehorcht und gesagt, die Orks beschleunigen die Schritte und wir laufen denen hinterher mit unserem Tross. To be continued on season two of Tross. Tross, nee, die Gefährten der Tross. Der Herr der Ringe, die Gefährten der Tross. Artikel, die Artikel. Der Artikel der Film, Artikel der Film. Ja, aber finde ich auch mal schön zu sehen, dass man das auch mal abbildet, was da was ist. Ja, da bist du an was dran, das glaube ich ganz fest. Ja, aber ich finde es immer wieder interessant, wenn du davon erzählst, weil manchmal steckt ja auch in dieser krassen realistischen Darstellung ja auch wieder eine Faszination. Ja. Weil diese, das ist mal zu sehen, diese krasse Menge an Pfeilen. Aber genau, so war es. Also wir haben den Hut hochgeworfen und dann habe ich meinen wieder gesucht, gefunden und behalten. Dann weggeworfen beim Umzug. Aber jetzt verraten wir bitte, warum da so ein US-amerikanischer Einschlag bei euch geherrscht hat. Ich habe jetzt noch nicht so viele Abschlüsse gemacht, dass ich jetzt keine andere Referenz kenne. Ich weiß nicht, ob das nicht üblich ist. Also gut, in Süddeutschland, wir hatten natürlich... Nein, du hast keinen Abschluss. Ich habe den Abschluss leider knapp verpasst. Ich war trotzdem auf der Abschlussparty. Knapp verpasst, also um sechs Semester verpasst, ja. Aber uns hat jeder … Weil du gefilmt hast? Ich habe den Abiball von meinem Nachfolgestudiengang gefilmt. Übrigens alle Menschen, die Abibälle, alle älteren Männer, die Abibälle filmen wollen, freiwillig, erst mal mal Festplatte untersuchen.
So einmal mal, es gibt so Berufe, wo ich denke, die kann man mal.
Aber ist Abiball nicht der Punkt, ab dem man erwachsen ist?
Also ist es nicht genau der Punkt, wo man sagt, da geht's, ran da, oder also jetzt im Sinne von,
es war auf jeden Fall sehr unangenehm für mich zu filmen, weil ich war der einzige Versager, der quasi von dem übergeordneten Jahrgang noch dabei war. Aber ich war immer noch quasi Ehrenmitglied der Film AG und deswegen wurde ich gefragt, weil ich anscheinend die ruhigste Hand an der Kamera habe. Oh, das ist cool, das ist cool. Du hättest gerne die ruhigste Hand am Bogen, hast aber die ruhigste Hand an der Kamera. Bei mir war es ja tatsächlich so, dass wir früher auch auf Basis von der Ringe alle Bogenschießen cool fanden. Jeder hat sich einen Bogen gebaut, Haselnuss, klar, später Eibe. Ich bin extra in den Garten von meinem Nachbarn eingebrochen für einen Eibenast und so, bla bla bla. So, und dann haben wir alle Bögen gebaut, hatten alle Spaß, haben auf Trendy-Eistee-Tüten geschossen, weil es Spaß gemacht hat und so. Und dann wurde es aber irgendwann ernst und alle meine Freunde haben gesagt, nee, wir sind jetzt in den Bogensportverein eingetreten. Und Bogensportverein heisst ja Fieberglasbogen, Visier, Auslösemechanismen, Flaschenzug, Sehne und all das. Und ich fand das abstossend, ich habe das angewidert. Die haben dir doch gesagt, das hast das hast du glaube ich vor ein paar Folgen mal gesagt, dass es da für andere Namen gibt. Du meinst intuitives Schießen. Genau, und dann meinten die, es gibt ja auch noch intuitives Schießen. Das ist mir wieder zu esoterisch. Das heißt, da war ich raus und da habe ich gemerkt, Moment mal, wir haben den Bogen für was ganz anderes geliebt. Ich habe ihn für seine Naturverbundenheit geliebt, für seine Unmittelbarkeit. Und die für so einen merkwürdigen sportlichen Ehrgeiz mit so Fiberglas und Lupenbrille scheiß. Genau, und ihr habt ihn für seine reine Zerstörung, präzise Zerstörungskraft geliebt, womit ich gar nichts anfangen konnte. Und das ist, ja, schade. Du hast gerade gesagt, Kreuz und Schlitz, um den Gag zu machen, fand ich fantastisch, dass die Bögen nicht kompatibel sind. Meiner Erfahrung nach kriegt man mit Schlitzschraubenziehern Kreuzschrauben ganz gut rein und raus gedreht. Richtig, aber andersrum eben nicht. Eben. Das ist eine Einbahnstrasse. Eben. Aber das ist ein typischer Fall von, warum gibt es das eine? Ja. Das braucht es nicht. Und dann gibt es noch die Sterne. Ja, das ist eine Abomination. Aber selbst da hilft ein Schlitzschraubenzieher manchmal schon, wo ein Kreuz auch nicht hilft. Nee, aber die haben ja fünf Zacken, die Sterne, dass du gerade nicht, dass die Geradheit … Glaub mir, es geht. Stefan, ich respektiere deine Praxiserfahrung als Handwerker, aber auch du kannst nicht die geometrischen Grundlagen der Sternform mit deiner Praxis einfach vom Tisch wischen. Du kannst, aber es geht einfach rein geometrisch, Vektor, es ist nicht möglich. Vektor ist ganz anderes, kein Abfluss. Einfach nicht mehr Abfluss. Okay, ich habe geworfen. Heißt ja nicht, dass ich gar keine Ahnung von gar nichts habe. Ich habe einen Hut geworfen. Uwe, ich habe einen Hut. Je höher der Hut, ist so größer. Ich habe einen Hut gelassen, ich habe den Hut in der Hand. Aber ja, Stern, das Einzige, was er mir erklären konnte, ist Stern, weil ich bei meiner Zivildienststelle sollte ich außen ein Schild dran montieren. Und dann hat mein Chef gesagt, ja, nimm da mal bitte Sternschrauben, sonst schrauben die Kinder das ab.
Und da dachte ich mir, okay, diese Kinder, die mit Schlitz und Stirnkreuz schrauben, ziehen durch die Gegend auf und alles demontieren, also die einfach auf Demontage sind.
Ist nichts niederlagelfest da draußen.
Genau, das war doch vor TikTok, ich glaube, heute hingen Kids auf TikTok rum. Früher haben sie demontiert, einfach alles auseinandergestraubt, was ging, aber man konnte sie schlagen. Es gab eine Chance, der Sternschraube. Es ist so interessant, weil da, wo ich wohne, da wird, sobald ein Fahrrad draußen steht, ist es sofort, also ein wertvolles Fahrrad, wird sofort geklaut. Sofort. Wirklich, es steht eine Nacht an und es ist weg.
Es ist wirklich spannend zu beobachten. Das habe ich auch mal erzählt, einmal habe ich der Leute gestellt.
Der einzig mutige Moment meines Lebens vielleicht. Sankt Stefan, Sankt Stefan. Ähm, äh, und dann, ähm, aber zum Beispiel gibt's einen, einen Schritt weiter quasi, zugänglich auch, wären so Gartenmöbel. Ja. Die klaut niemand. Nee. Wertvoller teils als ein Fahrrad. Weil sie nicht mobil sind, die bieten keine gute Fluchtmöglichkeit. Das Fahrrad ist ja deswegen so geil, weil das, was du klaust, automatisch deine Fluchtmöglichkeit ist. Wohingegen ein Stuhl ist ja das Gegenteil. Ein Stuhl verdammt dich ja zur Statik. Nein, ist keine Immobilie. Du musst dich hinsetzen. Also eine Immobilie kannst du nicht klauen, weil eine Immobilie hält dich fest. Es ist schon eine Immobilie, aber eine sehr eingeschränkte Immobilie. Es ist eine Immobilie mit Anführungszeichen. Es ist so semi-mobil. Es lädt nicht zur Mobilität ein, es lädt eher zur Ruhe ein. Und der Dieb will keine Ruhe ein. Das fand ich so genial, diese Game Mechanic bei GTA, wo man ja, wenn man einen Stern hat und gesucht wurde, mit dem Auto in eine Werkstatt reinfuhr und das Auto hat umlackieren lassen und dann einen Stern weniger oder zwei. Das fand ich so gut immer. Weil ja, natürlich, wie verwirrend. Ja, ja. Was denken die denn den Polizisten? Wie verwirrend ist das denn? Ja, ja, klar. Wir suchen nach einem weissen Auto. Sorry, gibt es nicht mal solche Spiele irgendwann einfach, die in Echtzeit entstehen können? Du kannst ja jetzt auch schon Filme prompten, einfach anhand eines Promts, sondern zwei Sekunden später hast du dann den Film, den du gerade hingeschrieben hast. Wird das nicht die Zukunft von Games sein? Also das Spiel wird in Echtzeit generiert. Um dich herum, was du willst, also so AI-Rollenspiele. Also das gibt es in gewisser Weise schon, dass die Welt um dich herum generiert wird, wo du hingehst, aber das ist halt keine KI, soweit ich will. Nee, aber so, stell dir vor, so DSA oder D&D, und du schreibst dann zum Beispiel rein oder sagst es in der Mikro, das ist ja auch so Speech-to-Text ja auch gut, sagst, ja, ich sehe da hinten eine Burg und ja, ich möchte mit der Wache am Eingang sprechen. Und dann gehst du mit WASD und der Maus, gehst du dann da hin und dann entsteht halt, gehst du über diese Kuppe und dann siehst du halt diese grosse Burg, die ist dann generiert worden, das kann ja nicht so schwer sein. Und dann ist dann eine Wache generiert worden. Bestimmt, ja. Und dann so eine Computerstimme, dann nimmt der Computer und sagt dann, okay, ist eine Wache, das hat eine tiefe männliche Stimme, okay, blablabla, dann redest du mit der, dann kannst du in deinem Mikrofon sagen, kann ich rein, kann ich in die Burg? Nee, nein, Sire. Ich würde aber gerne in die Burg. Ich habe hier einen Termin. Das ist nämlich das Problem. In dem Moment, in dem du alles automatisch generieren kannst, gibt es nichts mehr, was dich auffällt. Das ist nämlich auch mein Problem mit KI-Filmen. Wenn du einen Film schaust und der ist KI generiert und du sagst, na, ich möchte, dass jetzt Timothy Chalamet auftritt. Ich will, dass jetzt Timothy Chalamet auftritt, in der nächsten Szene. Und die KI so,
oh Mann, ey, das hat, okay,
gut, wie so Notes von so einem Producer, der keine Ahnung hat. Und dann so, okay, gut,
ich schreibe irgendwie Timothy Chalamet rein,
ich will, dass jetzt Aliens kommen, in der nächsten
Szene. Und die KI macht das alles.
Aliens sind da, ja. Aliens sind da, und am Ende
hast du einfach einen total überladenen Film, der keinen Sinn ergibt,
aber das, was du willst. Nee, das ist immer Porn.
Du hast am Ende immer Porn. Immer Porn, das wird so spannend werden. Aber ich freue mich auch drauf. Also das ist auch mega geil. Man muss ja auch sagen. Ja, jeder Film kann schlagartig zum Porn werden. Jeder Film wird schlagartig zu Porn. Wenn du zehn Köpfe hast und auf die kommt so ein Helm, der so in Echtzeit generiert, was das Gehirn gerade will, in neun von zehn Fällen und der eine hat gerade vorher noch masturbiert, sonst wäre das auch anders, ist da ein Sexfilm zu sehen. Ja, das stimmt schon. Schmuddel. Menschen sind Schmuddelköpfe. Aber die Frage ist, wie geht es dann halt weiter, ne, weil ich meine, dann ist der Pornoteil vorbei und dann aber jetzt kommen die Aliens so und dann aber alle Stunde oder so driftet es immer wieder in Porno ab oder so. Die Wissenschaftler müssen dann immer so vorscrollen, die nach einer halben Stunde ist dann so, okay, was kam dann? Genau, was kam dann nach? Weil da werden die eigentlichen Bedürfnisse befriedigt. Ja, lieb ich. Wenn der Sexteil durch ist, dann worum geht es eigentlich, was willst du eigentlich danach? Schlafen. Zeig mir Sterne, zeig mir Schafe. Ja, vermutlich ist es das. Ich finde es interessant. Das wird eine spannende, spannende, spannende Zeit. Das wird eine richtig spannende Zeit, wo wir richtig viel, richtig viel angucken müssen. Wir müssen einfach, wir können, brauchen sonst niemanden mehr. Wir brauchen niemanden mehr, ausser ... Man kann sich nicht unterhalten, das ist das Problem. Ja, das stimmt, ausser mit einem K.I. Stephan. Und ich sage, gib mir Stephan, aber ohne diese Arroganz, ohne dieses, das ist keine echte Musik, oh, Mundhinsen, so, ohne den Teil. Doch, du verstehst mich nicht falsch, du verstehst mich mal wieder falsch, das ist natürlich tolle Musik, es ist aber leider so toll, dass alle das immer spielen und dann macht es sich ja ja nicht mehr besonders. Es ist ja kein Arroganz, es ist einfach nur eine Beobachtung. Und ich will euch da draußen helfen. Ihr beobachtet niemanden mehr mit der Mondscheinsenate. Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry. Jeder kennt diese Videos, wo ihr das gelernt habt, mit diesen Punkten, die so runterkommen auf die Tasten. Ja, ist okay. Nicht jeder muss Noten lernen, nicht jeder muss Noten lernen. Ist völlig okay. Ja, ist völlig in Ordnung Ordnung. Aber jeder kennt das inzwischen. Die Entzauberung ist so krass. Ja, guck mal, all die Leute, die jetzt gerade die Mondscheinsonate spielen als Intro fürs Podcast-Ufo, sind jetzt demotiviert. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, was Florian mit seinem Intro gemeint hat, dass die Leute Highway to Stairway, Highway to Heaven, Stairway to Hell als Intro einreichen, was tatsächlich ab und zu passiert, dass Leute einfach ein Lied spielen und es so cool, aber... Noch gibt es sowas wie Urheberrecht. Noch. Es ist relativ selten, dass du irgendeine Sitcom hast oder eine Serie oder irgendwie sowas, Alle gegen Dad oder irgendwie eine neue Sitcom und das Intro ist einfach Hey There Delilah, einfach so. Das ist einfach der Song und da denkst du, okay, okayer Song irgendwie, den man mal mochte, aber man mag ihn jetzt nicht mehr, weil man nicht an die Person erinnert werden will, die man war, als man den Song mochte. Auch wenn der Song gar nichts dafür kann, aber ich habe ihn immer noch aus irgendeinem Grund auf Nummer eins meiner meistgespielten Songs. Und es erinnert mich daran, dass ich eigentlich mittlerweile denke, weiter zu sein,
aber der Song ist immer noch gut.
Also höre ich nur mal rein, aber trete ich mich im Kreis, wenn ich nie darüber hinausgehe, wer ich war.
So, das ist halt das Problem.
Aber die Show ist gut, alle gegen Dad.
Einfach so ein Typ, wo die Kinder wieder bei ihm einziehen.
Also so ein Dad.
Das gibt's?
Dad, ja, echt? Ach so, nee, was ist die Frage. Nee, ich dachte, alle gegen Dad, ich pitch das gerade. Ach so, du pitchest gerade. Also so ein Dad, der hat Kinder bekommen und dachte sich, oh fuck, mein ganzes Leben ist ruiniert, ich habe keine Zeit mehr für mich. Oh, noch ein Kind, noch ein Kind, warum kriegen wir es nicht hin? Ja, warum keine Basitomie, Basitomie wo? Das ist mein Alternativtitel. Und dann die Kinder, und dann endlich sind die ausgezogen, das ist sehr hervorspannend, das ist das Intro. Okay. So im Zeitraffer. Immer, so bei Powerpuff Girls, wo immer die Origin-Story eben... Genau, so ein bisschen wie Up, wo du so 15 Minuten so die Vorgeschichte, und dann sind die Kinder raus. 15 Minuten? Und du siehst ihn, so die Kinder fahren weg mit so einem Umzugswagen irgendwie in die Unistadt nach Heidelberg oder so und der Vater so setzt sich auf die Couch und plötzlich Ding Dong, Tür geht auf, Kinder sind wieder da, ziehen wieder ein zu Hause, Papa ist genervt, muss jetzt damit umgehen, dass seine nervigen Kinder da sind und das ist die Sitcom. Denn das Leid von Menschen ist lustig. Und Sitcoms auch immer noch? Fragezeichen? Ja, klar! Welche, was so eine neue... Fresh Prince, macht Spaß! Nicht eine Sitcom, die wir damals alle toll fanden, sondern jetzt eine aktuelle Sitcom, die du mir gegeil fandest. The Paper zum Beispiel. Eine Serie so ähnlich wie The Office, man sagt, oh, The Office ist so erfolgreich, haben wir gar keine anderen Ideen, haben wir gar keine anderen Ideen, Ricky Gervais, hast du gar keine anderen Ideen, nein, okay, dann lass uns einfach das gleiche nochmal machen, kommt jetzt bald raus, The Paper, es gab ja das kanadische The Office, was so ein bisschen gefloppt ist, jetzt gibt es nochmal The Paper. Okay, das wollen wir deine grossen The Office Rankings haben. Naja, okay, UK oben, dann US, dann Gär und dann …
Stromburg?
Ja. die großen The Office-Rankings haben. Naja, okay, UK oben, dann US, dann Gare und dann … Stromberg? Ja, und dann vielleicht noch … Ich habe mal versucht, ins Französische reinzuschauen, weil ich Französisch lernen wollte. Du mal gelernt hast, ja. Aber ich habe es nicht gerafft, habe es nicht gecheckt. Ist auch ein Drama, ist auch ein bi-ernsches Drama. Ist ein bi-ernsches Drama, alle rauchen und ständig kommen die Deutschen und übernehmen alles. Alle rauchen, haben so Sartre-eske Existenzialismusgespräche und am Ende muss diese Papierfirma auch einfach dicht machen. Ja, und sie schauen einfach immer auf die dunkle Strasse, es regnet, es ist sehr deprimierend irgendwie. Aber jedes Land hat seine eigene Interpretation. Deswegen wollte ich das nämlich machen, weil ich dachte mir, okay, ich kenne The Office und jede Interpretation bringt ja was von der eigenen Kultur rein. Stromburg, würde man ja schon sagen, Stromburg ist sehr deutsch, obwohl die Idee ja aus England kommt, aber man trotzdem ist deutsch interpretiert mit diesem Drögen. Aber es ist irgendwie ähnlich, aber doch deutsch. Also entweder sind wir alle gleich am Ende oder man bringt seinen eigenen kulturellen Hintergrund mit rein. Und deswegen finde ich es ja so spannend, das so als quasi so eine Achse der Menschheit zu haben. Jedes Land hat die Office und du musst nur die Office in jedem Land schauen, um genau zu verstehen, ah, die machen das anders, ah, Bürokultur ist so und so da und ah, das ist anders. Deswegen dachte ich mir, schaue ich französisches die Office an. Japanische, ich glaube, es ist auch spannend, wo es gar kein Problem gibt. Sehr lustig, aber es gibt kein Problem. Überhaupt kein Problem.
Niemand hat ein Problem mit dem. Es läuft auch spannend, wo es gar kein Problem gibt. Sehr lustig, aber es gibt kein Problem.
Überhaupt kein Problem. Niemand hat ein Problem mit dem. Es läuft auch sehr gut, es ist eine bekannte ...
Ist extrem gut. Es ist eine sehr gute Firma. Ja, ja. Also alles wunderbar und der Chef ist kompetent.
Alles sehr geordnet, sehr schickes Büro. Wunderbar und es ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Es läuft alles kein Problem. Keine Args aber auch. Ich mag meinen Chef.
Ich auch, ich mag dich. Ja, dankeschön. Pap damals überhaupt nicht lustig, also alles geklaut, alles Green Day. Nee, aber ich meine, das ist ja für Musiker wirklich deprimierend. Also ich kenne die Geschichte von so einem Musikproduzenten, der dann irgendwie ins Studio geht, abends, und der Musiker einfach völlig, völlig im Rausch, im Komponierrausch und wirklich so, ah krass und hier und da noch die Strophe und alles so. Und ich habe die ganze Nacht durchgearbeitet und hier ist der Song, spielt den ab und er meint. Freude schöner geterfunden, Tochter aus Elysium. Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, warte mal, Doktor Dre, Doktor, Herr Doktor, das ist Beethoven. Das ist Beethoven. Das ist Beethoven eins zu eins. Ich weiss nicht, was er sagt. So, und für den Musiker ist das, perfekte Dr. Dre-Imitation, und für den Musiker ist es sehr traumatisch, weil er denkt, er hätte einen riesen Welttipp geschrieben. Wie wir, also die Folge sich hier in Rage reden, sich lustig machen, Gags kloppen und am Ende merken, jetzt war alles schon mal besser in Harmontown. Ja, ja, es stimmt. Man kommt nicht drum rum. Nein, man kommt nicht drum rum. Steal like an artist. Don't be a dick about it. But, naja, Steal like an artist, aber ist ja bewusst zu stehlen. Hier geht es ja um nicht bewusst zu stehlen quasi, oder um... Ja, aber Ste Gnade sagt ja auch, es ist für you okay, weil am Ende ist er doch deins und bla bla bla. Okay. Am Ende ist er doch deins, weil am Ende, wenn du es umsetzt und so und es dann versucht, dich daran … Also auch, Idolen nachzueifern, heisst ja auch, dann vielen nachzueifern, am Ende kommt das alles durch deinen Filter und bei uns ist es halt nur Dan Harmon.
Ja, das ist leider das bisschen das Problem, ja, aber gut, wir werden da vielleicht noch andere finden.
Ich habe auch mal versucht zu komponieren. Also ist ja nicht so, klar, ich meine, komponieren ist einerseits, man denkt sich ja irgendwie so, manche Melodien sind ja so irgendwie, ähm, Funkel, Funkel, kleiner Stern, ne, komm, ne, so, und da, ne, Funkel, Funkel, das kriegst du nicht hin, Funkel, Funkel, kleiner Stern, das ist halt, einfach,d, d, d, d, d, d, d, d, einfach nur der gleiche Ton zweimal.
Es ist das gleiche Hoch wie runter.
Es ist so simpel.
Man denkt sich, das krieg ich nicht hin.
Wir nehmen zweimal A, wie so eine Subway-Bestellung, zweimal A, zweimal B, dann zweimal C, einmal D, fertig. Und alle sagen genial, genial, weil es ist ja so simpel, aber es ist dann am Ende doch schwer, am Körbier zu komponieren. Aber jetzt für mich diese nervige Kunstdebatte, also ich finde das eine sehr gute Frage, aber jetzt für mich diese Malewitsch ist ein gemaltes Quadrat, das kann ich ja auch und es ist deswegen keine Kunst. Nee Ich wollte gerade das Gegenteil machen, ich wollte gerade sagen, nachdem es passiert ist, wirkt es super simpel. Ich meine, du kannst ja auch bei Beethoven, das ist die Melodie, aber es ist mega geil. Aber rückblickend guckst du, ist super simpel, aber wenn du dir ans Klavier sind, denkst du, das so schwer sein, so eine Symphonie, das krieg ich auch noch hin. Ich habe immer noch meine Malphase, möchte ich sagen, und ich habe eine Sache gecheckt, weil, klar, uns nervt das ja immer schon, dieses, gibt es ja auch viele so KollegInnen, die dann immer diesen Gag machen mit, ja, ich lege mir meine Handtasche ins Museum und mal gucken, wer ist der erst fotografiert, und man denkt, Jesus Christ, ich hasse das, was ist für eine Kritik. Und dann auch immer das Quadrat oder so, keine Ahnung, abstrakte Kunst kam. Ist das Kunst oder kann das weg? Ja, ganz schrecklich, und dann, das kann ich auch malen und so. Und ich habe, unabhängig von dieser ganzen Originalitätsdebatte, und du erstmal die Idee haben und so und es ist ja auch die Erarbeitung und der Weg dahin, darum geht es oder was politischer Kontext oder was auch immer Aussage, mal davon abgesehen habe ich gemerkt, dass durch meine Malphase, was immer nicht kommt dann von Leuten, die unsere Perspektive haben, ist, es ist einfach Es mutig, das aufzuhängen. Es ist einfach irre, irre, irre mutig. Also, weil ich habe auch gedacht, das ist ja auch, was ich machen will, was runtergerocktes, kleines Minimalistisches. Aber find da mal was, wo du dann sagst, ja, das finde ich jetzt cool. Weil ich habe ein paar Sachen gemalt, dann kamen Freunde nach Hause und dann stand es dann noch rum, leider habe ich vergessen wegzuräumen, und die so, ist es fertig? Und dann gegrinsend. Hä, ist es fertig? Freunde auch mal im dicken Anführungszeichen. Ist es fertig? Ja. Kleiner ist Idiotenschwein. Planst du eine Ausstellung? Nein! Nee, aber ich sag nur, es ist einfach sehr, sehr mutig, so was Einfaches abzugeben oder allein mal jemanden anzurufen und so, also, der wollte mich, wollte mich ausstellen, dass mein Bild, wie alban ist das denn bei so was, bei so was Minimalistischem. Wenn du jetzt krass figurativ malst und so ein Shit, ja, der Anruf fällt dir erstmal leichter.
Kann immer noch doof gefunden werden, aber handwerklich ist es ganz toll.
Aber handwerklich, was willst du denn dazu sagen bei abstrakter, einfacher Kunst? Ich finde, das ist ein Aspekt, der auch vergessen wird. Trau dich mal, so einen Scheiss ins Museum zu hängen oder jemanden überhaupt anzubieten als zu verkaufen. Ja, das ist der eigentliche Mut. Der eigentliche Mut des Künstlers ist nicht das Erschaffen, sondern das zeige ich jemandem.
Genau. Wer weiss, wie viele Kunstwerke in irgendwelchen Kellern lausen, hausen, die man eigentlich zeigen könnte, aber der Künstler ist nicht von sich selber überzeugt. Jonathan Wieser hat gesagt, man muss es als Künstler lernen, auszuhalten. Man muss es bei sich aufhängen und aushalten. Wenn man es aushalten kann, dann ist es fertig. Aber das ist genau das richtige Wort, weil wenn ich dann meinen kleinen Scheiss male und ich finde das irgendwie cool, habe ich so noch nicht gesehen und es ist irgendwie minimalistisch und bla bla bla, hängt man auf, aber ich halte das ja nicht aus. Ich könnte auch, glaube ich, nie ein Bild malen, weil ich glaube, ich würde irgendwann an einem Punkt kommen, wo ich es okay finde und dann denke ich mir, jetzt hätte ich Angst davor, es mit jedem weiteren Pinselstrich zu ruinieren. Das kennt man ja, wenn man so rudimentär mal so ein Bild malt und denkt man sich, es sieht gar nicht schlecht aus. Oder ich habe zum Beispiel so Miniaturenfiguren bemalt oder so. Und man denkt sich, es sieht gar nicht schlecht aus, jetzt muss ich nur noch die Hose malen. Und man malt die Hose und denkt, ruiniert. Absolut ruiniert. Ich habe auch so Reveilautos bemalt, ruiniert. Nicht nur die Hose ist eine Katastrophe, sondern die Hose reisst alles andere mit sich runter. Und ich hatte immer so riesen, es ist so lustig, sich rückwirkend. Ich habe meine Sammlung auch nochmal abfotografiert und die schaue ich ab und zu an von den Miniaturen, die ich bemalt habe. Das sind so Warhammer-Figuren. Warhammer-Figuren, aber auch Herr der Ringe-Figuren. Ich habe angefangen mit Herr der Ringe mit dem Tabletop-Abenteuer. Danke, dass du mir diese Tür aufmachst. Ich gehe gerne durch. Ich habe angefangen mit Herr der Ringe, weil ich bin ja
großer Herr der Ringe-Fan tatsächlich.
Als Kind habe ich ja auch die
Filme gesehen tatsächlich. Hast du auch aus
Eibenholz gebaut? Aus Eibenholz, genau.
Da musste ich extra in den Garten von meinen Nachbarn
einbauen und dann habe ich auf Trendy Eisteeflaschen geschossen.
Erzähl ich wann anders. Ja, ja.
Und dann habe ich tatsächlich mit den Herr der Ringe-Figuren
angefangen, kam dazu über Warmer Fantasy,
später Warmer 40k und so weiter, also Fantasy
und dann auch Science Fiction, sagen wir mal,
sowas in der Richtung. Und dann habe ich die Figuren
Vielen Dank. Dann habe ich tatsächlich mit den Herr-Ringe-Figuren angefangen, kam dazu bei Warmer Fantasy, später Warmer 40k und so weiter, also Fantasy und dann auch Science-Fiction, sagen wir mal, sowas in der Richtung. Und dann habe ich die Figuren bemalt und ich hatte rückblickend immer grosse Schwierigkeiten mit den Augen. Die Augen sind sehr schwer zu bemalen, weil die sind ja winzig klein bei den Miniaturen und du willst aber trotzdem das Weisse und das Schwarze schon noch sehen, du willst es hinkriegen. Ach du heiliges Kanonenrohr. Hast du auch so einen kleinen Monokel in deinem Auge gehabt, damit du nah rangehen kannst?
Nee, nee, nee, das nicht, das nicht.
Was so Uhrenmacher haben.
Weil das Problem ist, die Augen, also es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten.
Entweder du machst erst alles weiss und versuchst, dann einen ganz dünnen schwarzen Strich zu malen, um dann unter den Augen die Hautfarbe aufzutragen.
Aber ein Strich ist leichter zu malen als ein Punkt.
Bei einem Punkt, da hast du dann die ganze Farbe auf einem Punkt,
und das ist blöd, aber einen Strich kannst du so von über der Augenbraue runter malen,
ganz dünn, und dann kriegst du es hin.
Und rückblickend bei vielen meiner Miniaturen habe ich einfach die Farben verwechselt.
Und ich habe schwarze Aussen und Weissehnen.
Und man denkt sich, daran scheitert es einfach. Aber krass, die Advanced-Technik, auf die ich im Leben nicht gekommen wäre, was Sinn macht, weil es nicht zu viel Farbe ist, wenn du dann diesen Punkt machst. Aber diese Advanced-Technik hast du dir drauf geschafft. Und dann schlagartig nach dem Beenden des Videos bei YouTube Motivation vorbei. Ja, und ich schaue mir heute die Figur und denke mir, die Augen, irgendwas ist da komisch, oder? Und es ist einfach eine weisse Iris vor schwarzem Augenapfel. Wie, gruselig, gruselig. Total gruselig. Und es ist komisch bei selbst, bei Miniaturen, ja, das ist irgendwie so ein Typ in Plattenrüstung mit einer riesigen Standarte, wo ein grosser Greif drauf ist. Plattenrüstung und mit, ja? Aber du schaust trotzdem, Standarte? Du schaust dem trotzdem in die Augen. Was komisch ist, weil die Augen sind nicht das Interessante. Das ist vielleicht irgendein Orkkrieger mit einer blutigen Axt und dem Kopf von einem Menschen in der Hand. Sitz auf einem Little Drachen. Sitz auf einem Drachen, aber du schaust, na die Augen, die Augen sind vorzusehen. Eigentlich sind Menschen süß. Eigentlich sind Menschen süß. Eigentlich ist es nicht süß. Du hast gerade gesagt, Menschen sind Schmuddelköppe, die alle an Sex denken. Ja, das stimmt. Aber sie gucken auch erst mal den Menschen in die Augen. Es gibt eine einzige Warhammer-Miniatur. Also Warhammer gibt es schon ganz, ganz lange, seit vielen Jahrzehnten. Seit 4000 Jahren, Warhammer 4K. Genau, und ganz viele verschiedene Völker, da gibt es die Hochelfen, die Orks, die Goblins, all das. Es gibt unendlich viele Figuren, das ist ein sehr erfolgreiches Produkt für viele Jahre, mit bestimmt zehntausenden verschiedenen Figuren. Es gibt eine einzige Figur, die einen Penis hat. Ah, wirklich? Ja. Wieso? Warum hat die einen Penis? Ein Wieselbel-P wo kann ich die ... Also wo kann man die ... Es geht um die Waldelben. Waldelben natürlich sehr naturbelassen, also wenig Kleidung oder so mit Blättern oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung wenig jetzt Sachen. Reden wir jetzt von Warhammer oder Herr der Ringe? Nee, Warhammer. Warhammer. Würden wir über Herr der Ringe reden, hätte ich Waldelben gesagt. Habe ich vielleicht gesagt. Du hast Was hast du gesagt? Jetzt bin ich selber verwirrt. Ich meine Waldelfen. Ach so. Und da gibt es Reiter und einer der Reiter ist einfach nackt. Der sitzt einfach nackt auf dem Pferd. Auf dem Pferd? Und der Penis ist auf dem Pferd? Der Penis ist mit dabei. Der sitzt auch ohne Sattel natürlich, alles bei Waldelben sehr naturbelassen. Und es ist so merkwürdig, weil es passt ja total gut zu den... Was mich raten, ist eine sehr beliebte Figur. Es ist eine überdurchschnittlich beliebte Figur, aber einfach wegen diesem Kuriosum, weil es allein, weil hätten jetzt, sag ich mal, es gibt ja immer eine Modellart, sagen wir mal, Elfensperg-Träger. Und davon gibt es, sagen wir mal, fünf verschiedene Modelle. Und wenn du aber eine Armee hast aus denen, wiederholen die sich natürlich, aber es gibt fünf verschiedene Modelle. Das heißt, es gibt pro Typ verschiedene Modelle. Und hätten jetzt alle von diesen Waldelben Reitern, wären die alle nackt, dann würde man sagen, ah, okay, gut, das ist halt dein Ding. Aber nur eines dieser Modelle. Und Und fällt dann auch auf, wenn du die Armee von denen hast und du hast halt nur diese nackte Figur, ist halt weird. Genau. Hey, wollen wir tauschen? Vielleicht ein paar von meinen Waldelbenreitern gegen ein paar von deinen? Ich würde gerne, also den fände ich zum Beispiel ganz gut. Ja. Und den da. Oder vielleicht noch den, also halt die, also diese Art. Also die, die nackt sind. Ja, die. Also die, also du sagst ja auch die nackt auf. Achso, habe ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen. Aber achso, ja, die finde ich ganz gut. Klar, es ist natürlich ein Thema, und ich habe die sogar mal live gesehen, die ist recht alt. Also das sind fast schon Antiquitäten, die man da hat. Bestimmt. Weil jetzt fängt es nämlich an, also jetzt muss er natürlich, weil Tolkien hat ja sehr viel beschrieben. Ja. En detail. Ja, ja, ja. Sehr, sehr viel. Ja. Ich glaube, der Penis ist jeweils nicht der verschiedenen Völker, Mittel-Erdes. Nein, gar nicht. Es gibt ja so elbische Wörterbücher, auch so Webseiten, wo man sich übersetzen kann. Und ich natürlich mit meinem Schmuddelkopf, Penis, Brüste. Und gibt es keine Wörter dafür? Auch für Brüste nicht. Nein, gibt es keine Wörter einfach. Hupen, Glocken, gibt es keine Wörter dafür. Das ist ja eine bewusste Lehrstelle, die auffällt. Also wenn du eine Sprache machst, das Erste, was erlernst in der Sprache ist irgendwie Schimpfwörter und
Genitalien oder so, damit du dich auch nicht blamierst und das
aus Versehen sagst oder so. Aber bei Elbisch
nicht, da fehlt das einfach.
Ja, ich finde auch, es passt auch nicht so richtig zu
Fantasy. Also und irgendjemand hat auch alle
Fantasy-Franchises
gemeinsam, so eine Asexualität,
findest du nicht?
Harry Potter, genauso wie
Herr der Ringe, Narnia. Ja, du hast ja dann wieder sowas wie Game of Thrones, wo du Das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein und so. Aber weil es in der Fantasywelt so abwesend ist, fällt es deswegen mehr auf. Vielleicht fällt es da dann als Kontrastmittel mehr auf. Ja, gut, dann hast du aber recht, da wurde ich dann debunked. Okay, ja, interessant. Und diese Figur, und da hat man sich aber, da musste sich ja jemand entscheiden, das sind die Penisse von Elfen. Genau. Die sehen so aus, die Penisse. Ich glaube, ich habe es nicht mehr genau vor Augen. Warum haben die von Narnia, äh, die Navi, die Navi, wie heißen die nochmal? Ja, die Navi, ja, von Pandora. Pandora, genau. Wie heissen, also warum, die tragen ja Lendenshorts. Richtig. Da muss ja was runter sein, es sind ja keine Lendenshorts. Ja. Aber die haben ja auch, also. Die haben ja diesen Schwanz, oder? Die haben ja diesen Pferdeschwanz, diesen Stecker, wo man auch denkt, ist das das Geschlechtsteil? Nee, vermutlich nicht, aber normal ist. Ja. Aber diese Entscheidung, die will ja niemand treffen, die muss auch niemand treffen. Ja, ja. Es ist super komisch, wenn du Fantasy, Worldbuilding machst, wie du damit umgehst. Weil zum Beispiel auch Godzilla oder so, der hat ja keine Hose an. Das ist riesig, der ist riesig, der Mann. Ich weiss nicht, ob Godzilla männlich ist, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, oder? Ich glaube, Godzilla ist weiblich in der Originalfassung. Godzilla. Und kann sich ja aber von sich aus reproduzieren. Wir reden vom Roland-Emmerich-Film. Weiss ich nicht. Wir reden nicht vom Original, eigentlich aus den Fuffzigern.
Aber du musst ja ganz explizit in einem Design-Meeting, musst du ja mal festgelegt sein, so Herr Emmerich, zum Thema Charakterdesign ist von Godzilla. Also Godzilla ist ja riesig gross und wenn die jetzt durch Tokio marschiert, sieht man ja meistens so von unten. Also man steht ja oft zwischen den Beinen von Godzilla, wenn die über die hinweg marschiert und die Wolkenkratzer. Wie ist das denn? Ich weiß, ich habe ihr Resümee gesehen. Sie waren der einzige mit der nackten Figur von Warhammer. Gut, also ich habe jetzt viel gemacht, ich habe jetzt viel gearbeitet in verschiedenen Bereichen. Die Reputation ist bekannt, ich habe sie genommen, weil sie machen schon irgendwie cooles Zeug, aber irgendwie sie haben so einen komischen Fokus. Ich habe hier mal eine Skizze gemacht von Godzilla. Ach du Scheiße, holy shit, holy shit, ich nehme die mal an mich, um das jetzt zu konfiszieren. Naja, Godzilla ist auch weiblich, haben sie gesagt, und wenn du mal von unten da reinstehst. Ja, aber so weiblich. Das ist zu weiblich. Aber das ist ja irre weiblich. Das ist maximal weiblich, ja. Das geht in ihrem Kopf vor. Das geht in ihrem Kopf vor? Das sind normale Organe. Sie hat ja auch Beine und Ohren und so. Warum soll sie dann nicht eine riesige... Sind das Tränen in ihren Augen? Das ist wunderschön. Ja, aber man muss sich immer damit auseinandersetzen. Also hat Goofy eine Hose an oder nicht oder wer schon, das ist auch nervig. Aber wenn du jetzt wie die Navi, sagen wir mal, die haben keine Geschlechtsteile, ist es trotzdem komisch, wenn die ohne Hose rumlaufen. Das hat dann so einen komischen Vibe irgendwie. Und es ist mega weird jetzt vielleicht, das alles zu sagen und so, aber die rennen ja auch und so und sind in so Kampfsituationen in die Navi, spielst du bei The Way of the Mortars, auch im zweiten Teil. Und die schwimmen da rum und haben diesen Ländenschutz an, der ist auch nicht so richtig festgebunden, der ist auch ganz klein und die sind ja auch ganz gross. Okay, hast du der Handlung überhaupt gefolgt in dem Film? Ich hab's versucht, irgendwas, das Geheimnis war unter Wasser. Okay, weil Das sind ja durchaus dramatische Szenen, die schwimmen ja um ihr Leben. Ich habe nur gedacht, das ist eine bewusste Entscheidung. Entweder haben sie keine Geschlechtsteile, weil die wären mal zu sehen gewesen. Jeder war schon mal im Schwimmbad, ist die Rutsche gerutscht. Wir sind alle nicht perfekt. Wir sind alle nicht perfekt. Die Badekleidung ist nicht perfekt.
Die Herren und Damen tragen Ländenschürze. Die sind nicht, bei weitem nicht, Riss und Biss fest. Nein, nein, nein. Und auch nicht strudelsicher. Nein. Also unter Wasser, du hast ja Strömung und Strudel, das ist ja alles, also das ist ja alles kreuz und quer. Ich meine, und dann kämpfen die da in einem Film und die schwimmen und die springen rein und das ist schon ein bewusster, klar, das ist ein Familienfilm, verstehe ich schon, aber das muss ein Eingang kennen. Oh, da sind viele erwachsene Themen, also weiß ich nicht, Familienfilme, da sind noch viele erwachsene Themen drin, also wie gehen wir mit der Natur um. Du findest Avatar 2, The Waves of the Waters ist ein Erwachsenenfilm? Ich finde einige Themen, die angerissen wurden. Zum Beispiel, was wäre denn so ein Thema? Naja, Rassismus. Rassismusdebatte, fremde Feindlichkeit. Also du hast die blauen Navi und du hast die grünen Navi. Und wie verstehen die sich, ne, und dann wie nehmen die jetzt die Menschen auf, die ohnehin schon ein schweres Standing haben, aber bei den grünen Navi dann nochmal besonders. Und das ist natürlich, da denkt man, okay, krass, wie ist das in der Welt? Und der Film hat ja eine ganz klare Lösung für dieses Rassismusproblem. Genau, nämlich akzeptiert man muss den Welt retten, damit man sich… Man muss den Gesang des Weltenbaums lauschen, um dann Aewa. Und der Weltenbaum ist an sich alle gleich. Aewa. Der Weltenbaum ist aber jetzt auch, kommt ja vom Planeten Pandora. Meinst du nicht, insgeheim bevollzugt der auch Pandorianer? Der ist ja auch nur an einer Stelle auf Pandora. Also, klar, verstehe ich total, aber ich verstehe, was du meinst, aber glaubst du, dass du jetzt wirklich, wenn du CGI animierst, auch natürlich die Physik dieser Körperteile mit beachten musst oder gerade nicht? Also gibt es da Übereinkünfte? Wir haben krassen Realismus inzwischen. Und dazu gehört ja auch, dass wenn Leute rennen, dann sieht man da vielleicht manchmal auch ein anderes... Ich meine nur... Ach so, du meinst jetzt gar nicht so durch die Kleidung, sondern dass es wirklich einmal rausschaut. Nicht, dass es will. Du legst mir jetzt so in den Mund, dass ich das will oder nur daran denke oder so. Ist das für dich denn dann ein normaler Anblick, dass du das regelmässig siehst in der Welt, dass dir das fehlt in Fiktion? Nein, nein, nein, nein, es fehlt mir gar nicht, auf das jetzt so zu formulieren. Ich finde das ein deutlich interessantes Thema, auch beim Thema Brüste zum Beispiel. Weil das Wasser da hat Blasen, ganz kleine Blasen, das ist crazy die Animation, die Simulation von Wasser. Dann macht jemand so eine Hand ins Wasser und dann wie das Wasser schäumen würde, so ein bisschen ab und zu. Das ist alles animiert, das ist jetzt, das ist fotoregistisch, das ist perfekt. Ja. Nimm keinen Blitz. Aber okay. Du denkst ja das bei Brüsten. Ich denke, weil es gibt diesen Trend unter Videospielen, dass man darüber lacht, haha, wie absurd werden Brüste animiert, irgendwie um natürlich die Gamer-Klischees, haha, die fahren darauf ab. Aber ich glaube, es ist als Mensch, der da diese Animation macht, nicht so leicht, den perfekten Grad zu treffen, weil du willst es realistisch animieren und wenn du in eine Richtung übertreibst, denken wir, wie peinlich ist das denn, was für eine pubertäre Scheiße, so ist es doch gar nicht, aber du willst es auch nicht comichaft zu fest irgendwie, also du musst ja auch, es ist ja auch unterschiedlich, es gibt ja auch unterschiedliche Konsistenzen, Viskuitäten, du musst ja, wenn du jetzt sagst, ich nehme das Thema ernst, dann musst du ja voll reingehen. So und dann musst du Simulationsprogramme, dann musst du Untersuchungen, das ist crazy, das ist unangenehm. Und das ist unangenehm, das ist auch unangenehm, ja. Ja, aber ich finde genau so. Du hast da halt bei Blender halt einen Regler, wie fest ist es und du machst halt irgendwas, weil du denkst, ja es gibt alles und es ist halt super super unangenehm. Wie du sagst, der Grad ist komplett super, super, super, super schmal. Aber Harry Potter zum Beispiel ist die Abwesenheit von jeglichem Sexuellen. Finde ich auch crazy. Na, es gibt doch diesen einen Traum, wo Ron und Hermine dann so nackt gezeigt werden im Sinne von, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was das ist, aber irgendwie, ich glaub, Harry stellt sich vor, dass die von ihm sich abwenden, weil die jetzt da zusammen ... zusammen sind oder so. Aber ich hab das nur noch ganz düster in Erinnerung. Er ist auf jeden Fall auch animiert, aber es ist halt so dieser Grad von ... Hey, pass auf, Emma Watson, wir animieren dich nackt. Du hast was anderes. Nur dass du es weisst. Okay, wirklich? Du hast was anderes animiert. Nein, hundertprozentig. Es gibt diese eine Szene, also ich finde, ab vier wird es eh furchtbar bei Harry Potter. Ja, ja. Das ist eh schrecklich, weil das ist so, wir wollen Hogwarts sehen. Wir reden über die Filme. Wir wollen Hogwarts sehen, nicht diesen Quatsch da. Aber auch die Bücher. Wir müssen fliehen und wir sind in irgendwelchen irischen Landschaften unterwegs, mir alles egal.
Und da gibt es ja dann aber auch diesen Storypoint, dass Harry sich entfernt von Ron und Hermine im Sinne von, die sind jetzt zusammen oder nicht oder was, keiner, was geht da, bin ich alleine und der hat ja eh zu kämpfen mit, bin ich Horcrux, ja oder nein, so. Und dann gibt es aber diese Szene, diesen Traum. Kennt jeder, super relatable. Diesen Traum, das ist eine Metapher, Stefan. Ja, du hast vielleicht nicht eine Teilseele eines dunklen Magiers in dir. Ich stelle dir vor, so würde man Fantasy, würde man die ganze Zeit unter Relatability-Standards nehmen. Kennt ihr das auch? Ihr seid verbannt auf eine schwarze Burg am Rente des Reichs, dann sterbt ihr und werdet wieder zum Leben erweckt. Ich kann nicht damit anfangen mit dem Scheiss, weil irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
ich habe jetzt noch keinen Ringanvertraut bekommen, den ich irgendwie in eine Feuerstadt bringen muss. Ja, was soll ich damit anfangen? Ja, ich kann nicht, man guckt das nicht so gerne sowas. Aber da war das auf jeden Fall auch Thema. Und dann gibt es ja auch so Backstage-Behind-the-Scenes-Material, wo es heißt, ja, es war unangenehm. Weil ich glaube, das war das Ding. Die Schauspieler von Ron und Hermine mussten sich ... Wenn sie beim Namen. Mussten ... Okay. Ich will ungern jetzt die Leute doxen, die haben auch ein Privatleben. Es ist Emma Watson und Rupert Grint. Die mussten irgendwie so diese Kussszene spielen, die aber dann quasi nicht als solche im Film benutzt wurde, sondern nur Teil der Animation von diesem Tagtraum oder von dieser Vision ist, was ja noch mal super unangenehm ist. Habe ich diesen Teil jemals gesehen? Also das ist alles sehr fremd. Wir wollen jetzt auch nicht so pubertär da immer nur die Brüste wackeln und der Lennenschutz, aber es ist, man muss sich damit leider beschäftigen. Interessant, wo die Grenze gezogen wird und warum das nicht, weil es einfach Teil vom Leben ist. Und das ist ja krass, das ist ausgelassen einfach. Weil es kann einen rausreissen. Man kennt das ja in Filmen, wenn jemand nackt ist, aber man halt gerade dann zensiert und da steht halt dann gerade der Briefkasten. Und es reisst so raus, aber es zu sehen reisst auch raus, weil man dann, es ist einfach blöd, der Mensch ist einfach zu schwanzig, zu schmuddelig.
Schmuddelkopp, es sind alles Schmuddelköppe und das ist auch eigentlich … Oder halt nur wir beide, man weiss es nicht genau. Ja, das werden wir in der Folge sicherlich erfahren. Ihr könnt uns übrigens immer wieder schreiben, auch über das Kontaktformular, freuen wir uns sehr auf das Postasuch.com. Dass wir zu schmuddelig sind? Nee, und eine spannende Frage, wir haben ja gerade immer noch die Trinkgeldwochen, vielleicht willst du das Trinkgeld? Ja, man weiß es nicht, es geht darum, wir wollen das System aufsprengen, da ist ganz gross was falsch und du hast den kleinen Witz, den kleinen Schabernack dir erlaubt, hast gesagt, wie ist das beim Drogenkaufen, beim Dealer, sagt man da auch manchmal, stimmt so? Ja. Und uns hat anonym ein Drogendealer geschrieben.
Wirklich?
Und gesagt, dass es nicht vorkommt, er kann uns beruhigen. Das ist noch nie vorgekommen. Es ist noch nie vorgekommen und er oder sie hat auch eine Theorie dazu und ich glaube, die ist sehr plausibel. Denn beim Drogenkaufen geht es ja schon darum, dass man sich gegenseitig das Gefühl gibt, man kann sich auf jeden Fall vertrauen. Wenn man sich das Gefühl nicht hat, dann gibt es ja die Transaktion auch nicht. Man muss sich also vertrauen können. Und dadurch betonen beide immer so ein freundschaftliches Verhältnis. Und dadurch entsteht eine Art Augenhöhe zwischen Konsumenten. Konsument, also ich interpretiere das jetzt alles rein, da stand da so nichts drin, aber ich glaube, da entsteht eine Art Augenhöhe zwischen Kunde und Verkäufer, dass es da nicht so etwas wie Trinkgeld gibt, auch nicht verlangt wird, also es wäre fast eher weird. Ich als jemand, der gar keine Ahnung davon hat, hätte jetzt eher das Gegenteil erwartet, dass man maximal distanziert ist.
Also ich denke jetzt so an Park und dann willst du so, ja, hier Koks oder was und dann steckt man sich das so zu. Aber welcher Park? Also dann gehst du da hin zu... Das weiss ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich meine, genau. Also vermutlich kriegt man die Nummer von irgendwem, von dem man kennt. Es ist eher wahrscheinlich eher freundschaftlich, Freund vom Freund und so. Ich glaube, es gibt unterschiedliche Arten von Drogen, es gibt die, die so ein entfernter Teil des Freundeskreises sind, wo man dann halt mal auch bei dem bleibt. Ich habe mal in einem Podcast gehört, dass es immer die Frage ist, raucht man dann beim Dealer noch ein oder so? Ich kann damit nichts anfangen. Nee, genau. Aber ich glaube, es gibt auch eine andere Art von Drogendealer, das ist halt so der Widertyp im Wald oder im Park. Und da ist es super distanziert. Das ist eine Outdoor-Idee. Also ich glaube, das ist ja gar nicht so frequentiert, dass es auch gar nicht gibt. Oder vielleicht, aber also ich kenne niemanden, der bei Leuten im Wald was kauft. Es ist immer irgendwie Kontakte oder so. Und da wird auch teilweise, kennt man die dann nicht, aber es wird irgendwie so, ja, es muss eine Vertrauensebene da sein. Und das kommt nicht zur, also das ist die grosse Drogen- und Sexfolge. Es ist natürlich auch die Frage, was ist ein guter Service eines Drogendealers? Also was ist dann Diskretion, Qualität? Diskretion, das erwartet man alles so. Das ist ja dann die Frage, es ist ja noch so dieses, ah, kauft ihr was? Du meinst, was ist es noch darüber hinaus, also der Service-Auspekt? Es ist, glaube ich, also dieses leichte Verbrecherische, glaube ich, eliminiert auch diesen, ach ja, kauf dir was Schönes, so dieses. Feudale. Ja, es ist zu ernst, ein Drogendeal ist vielleicht zu ernst, als dass man so, oh stimmt, so passt schon. Oder ist er so ehrlich, dass er das entlarven würde? Ich glaube, dieses Trinkgeldding ist einfach ein Überbleibsel aus dem fucking Mittelalter, wo die alten Männer, der hübschen Frau, die es bedient hat, Bauernmädchen, dann noch was zugesteckt hat, so ein Schwachseln. Das ist doch das Relikt von sowas. Mein Problem ist, ich habe leider eine Doku gesehen über die Geschichte des Trinkgelds, ich habe noch leider vergessen, was es ist.
Aber schaut euch gerne mal zum Thema Trinkgeld, schaut euch mal gerne die Last Week Tonight Folge an zum Thema Tipping, da wird das alles erklärt. Servus, grütti, hallo. Die reden nämlich auch über Trinkgeld. Die haben wir auch gehört, aber leider vergessen. Auch vergessen. Das ist so dumm einfach. Nee, aber ich meine, diese Ehrlichkeit einer Drogenhandlung, also eines Drogen, also der Deal ist ja, ich weiss, sie verkaufen mir Drogen, sie wissen, ich kaufe bei ihnen Drogen. Wir sind beide in diesem sehr, sehr ehrlichen Verhältnis. Ja.
Und in diesem ehrlichen Verhältnis hat das keinen Platz, dieses gönnerhafte, hier, bitteschön, das ist einfach eine Geste mit der Prämisse, es ist keine Augenhöhe da. Und das finde diese Drogenbeifelung deswegen so gut, weil es entlarvt diese Geste. Ich dachte nur gerade, es ist so ein bisschen, Trinkgeld gleicht den Mehr-Service der anderen Person aus. Also du kriegst dein Essen im Restaurant, aber der Service ist obendrauf. Das heißt, du zahlst für das Essen. Aber ein besonders netter Arzt kriegt kein Trinkgeld. Richtig. Der besonders sich Zeit nimmt und dir das erklärt. Genau, weil du beim Arzt ja für die Dienstleistung schon zahlst. Das machst du beim Kellner auch. Nee, beim Kellner zahlst du fürs Essen. Der ist angestellt bei einem Restaurant, zahlst du im Restaurant Geld. Ja, aber jetzt für die Dienstleistung schon zahlt. Das machst du beim Kellner auch? Nee, beim Kellner zahlst du fürs Essen. Der ist angestellt bei einem Restaurant. Er zahlt im Restaurant Geld. Ja, aber jetzt für die Logik. Ich zahl für mein Essen, aber den Kellner gebe ich sozusagen nochmal über was übernaus, damit seine Leistung auch gewürdigt ist. Es gibt Random-Berufe, die wurden rausgepickt und da gibt es einen Teil, der ... Aber haben wir da nicht gerade was gefunden. Trinkgeld gibst du, wenn du, wenn Service zusätzlich ist, also beim Handwerker. Die Dienstleistung des Handwerkers ist seine Arbeit in deinem Haus, also bezahlst du die. Beim Restaurant ist das, was du bezahlst, das Essen, die Arbeit des Kochs. Du willst aber zusätzlich noch die Arbeit des Kellners gotieren. Warum muss der Koch kein Trinkgeld, wenn er besonders lecker gekocht hat? Ja, weil der kriegt das Geld von dem Essen. Aber das ist nett, das funktioniert ja das betriebswirtschaftliche System Restaurant ja nicht. Wobei jetzt zum Beispiel beim Lieferservice, wenn du Pizza kriegst, das Geld, was du zahlst, ist für die Pizza, das Trinkgeld kommt noch obendrauf für den Pizzaboten. Der Pizzabote, es wird sozusagen als zwei Interaktionen behandelt. Aber beim Friseur, wo das Haare schneiden, die Dienstleistung schon ist, musst du kein Trinkgeld geben, weil die Handlung selbst schon der Kosten ist. Trinkgeld, auf Trinkgeld angewiesen. Nee, das ergibt für mich keinen Sinn, aber das funktioniert für mich nicht. Warum angewiesen? Nee, also es ist einfach ein großer Bestandteil des Friseurberufs, auch Trinkgeld.
Aber warum ist es dann nicht klar, dass man es geben soll?
Also dann muss aber auch die Friseurlobby da ein bisschen mehr daran arbeiten, dass man das weiss.
Ja, nee.
Du kannst nicht einerseits darauf angewiesen sein, aber auf andererseits macht es niemand und es gibt kein offenes Gespräch drüber.
Es ist eine Willkürlichkeit drin und ich glaube, das Muster, was du gerade suchen wolltest, existiert nicht. Also ich lasse mich gerne eines anderen Gegenteils überzeugen. Aber die Tatsache, dass es nicht jeder beim Friseur und beim Handwerker Trinkgeld gibt, zeigt für mich, dass es ein Unterschied ist, ob du für eine Dienstleistung zahlst oder ob du für ein Produkt zahlst, wo der Service quasi separat von einer separaten Person gemacht wird. So, zum Beispiel bei Subway oder so, wo die Person das Sandwich macht und dir dann gibt. Und du zahlst für das Sandwich und du zahlst für keine weitere Dienstleistung. Im Restaurant gibt es den Kellner, der dir das Essen bringt und du zahlst fürs Essen, aber zahlst den Kellner mit Trinkgeld. Du zst ja aber nicht bei allen Dienstleistungen Trinkgeld, das ist einfach nicht so. Genau, weil die schon Teil davon sind. Wenn du jetzt zu einer Massage gehst, zahlst du für die Massage. Das ist aber schon alles, was passiert ist, es gibt nicht noch den Kellner Teil. Nein, der Trinkgeldteil ist da, weil wir beschlossen haben, die verdienen zu wenig Geld, deswegen geben wir diesen Berufsgruppen mehr Geld. Das wissen ja aber die Leute, die diese Leute anstellen, die Löhne bleiben gleich, weil das so bekannt ist, dass es Teil einfach ist. Kellner verdienen einfach im Monat tausend Euro, weil sie sich trinken. Aber meinst du nicht, es gibt diese Doppelzahlung? Ich zahle mit den Kosten, die in der Speisekarte sind, zahle ich den Koch. Aber so funktioniert Restaurants nicht. Ja, aber jetzt von deiner Logik, es gibt ja Handlungen, Zahlungen. Du meinst menschliche Intuition. Genau, es gibt Zahlungen, wo sich Trinkgeld natürlich anfühlt und Zahlungen, wo sich Trinkgeld nicht natürlich anfühlt. Beim Friseur zum Beispiel. Warum gibt man einem frühen Friseur kein Trinkgeld? Genau, manche scheinen Trinkgeld zu geben, andere nicht, aber es ist kein natürlicher Reflex. Wohingegen, wenn du einen Kellner kriegst, dann kannst du sagen schon, oder du, keine Ahnung, jetzt bei so einem, wenn du irgendwie aufs, also das gibt es in Amerika oft in Serien, wenn du aufs Hotelzimmer geführt wirst, von diesem Pagen, der deinen Koffer trägt, dann sagst du, das Geld, das ich fürs Hotel zahle, ist für meinen Hotelaufenthalt, aber deine Leistung ist nochmal separat. Also kriegst du Trinkgeld. Vielleicht, weiss ich nicht, aber vielleicht ist das ein Einfallstor.
Ich habe auch diese Regel eigentlich, wenn es Tischservice gibt, Trinkgeld geben, wenn ich was to go hole, kein Trinkgeld geben, in Deutschland.
Das ist anders, aber in Deutschland würde ich kein Trinkgeld geben, wenn ich was to go kaufe.
Okay, ja.
Und dann gab es ein Restaurant hier in Hamburg, so ein Café, in dem ich war, vor unserer Aufzeichnung, und das war genau die Mitte. Da bin ich rein, wollte ab und einen Kaffee zu go bestellt, und dann haben die auch noch so was anderes gehabt, irgendwie so ein, weiss ich nicht, so ein Sandwich, was sie so noch gegrillt haben oder sowas. Und dann, ja, bringe ich den raus. Ich so, okay. Und dann habe ich mich draußen hingesetzt und dann haben sie es gebracht. Es gab keinen Service, also ich musste dann auch wieder reingehen zum Bezahlen. Das heißt, es gab keinen Service, es gab nur einmal den, der es gemacht hat, also es war auch nicht die Bedienung, sondern es war einer, der hinten das gemacht hat, der Koch, der einfach einmal dann rausgegangen ist, mitgebracht hat und wieder gegangen ist. Es gab keinen Tisch. Und da wurde ich da so selber überfüllt in meiner Regel, weil ich dachte, ja, aber das ist genau... Es ist schwierig. Und dann kriegt man das hingehalten, dieses Gerät, und dann kann man klicken auf 10, 12 und 15 Prozent. Ja. Das ist schwierig. Ja, das ist crazy. Ja, ja, aber genau, wir nähern uns langsam an. Ich gehe nicht mit mit deiner Definition. Ich glaube, das sind alles, alle Berufe, wo wir Trinker geben, sind Überbleibsel von so feudalem Shit, der Page, das Zimmermädchen, das ist so, aber auch Kellner und so, das ist einfach Oberschicht, Unterschicht, man gibt denen gönnerhaft Geld, das ist das, Machtdemonstration auch. Und ich mag das einfach nicht, ich finde es unangenehm, es ist unangenehme Geste, die sollen genauso viel bekommen, wie sie bekommen sollen, aber nicht mit diesem ... Stefan, ich habe ja den Trinkgeldboykott vorgeschlagen oder den Antiboykott, ich habe ja gesagt, geb allen Trinkgeld, ich weiß nicht, wie man das nennt. Aber da müssen wir kurz beissen, weil wir beiden sind auch so Introvertis, die jetzt, ich finde es ganz schlimm. Aber das ist halt ein Massenphänomen. Wenn alle mitmachen, fällt es leichter für das Individuum, aber es macht niemand mit. Ich weiss nicht, wie man das nennt, ein Antiboykott, also anstatt weniger zu machen, ganz viel zu machen. Durch Schwemmung. Genau, Schwemmung, Schwemmung. Und gebt einfach allen Trinkgeld für alles. Wenn ihr im Baumarkt zahlt, einfach Trinkgeld, wenn ihr auch eine Wurst holt, Trinkgeld, egal was, überall, wenn ihr in einer Baustelle vorbeifahrt, gebt denen Trinkgeld, überall, um alle einmal zu verwirren, um alle an einen grossen Tisch zu holen, damit wir es einmal klar regeln und dann sind wir zufrieden. Dann macht das bitte gerne. Die Technologie Union Union Union Union Union Union Union Union Union Wir sehen uns gerne nächste Woche und gucken ob das
Wir schauen gerne nächste Woche, ob das klappt oder nicht, ob die Welt eine bessere ist oder ob wir nochmal ran müssen. Das ist ein Thema, was sich in einer Woche durchaus klären kann. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, äh, vielen Dank an dich, Valentin. Jo, danke, bis zum nächsten Mal, danke Stefan, tschüss, bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss, danke fürs Zuhören, blablababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababab Oh, ich fliege noch mit der Voice-by-Production. Er muss für jedes Abenteuer zu haben sein und natürlich toll aussehen. Und er darf mich nie lang warten lassen. Klingt verdächtig nach dem neuen Ford Puma Gen E. Der lädt schneller als dein Smartphone, von 10 auf 80 Prozent in nur 23 Minuten. Hm, dann muss ich wohl mal Probefahren! Der neue Ford Puma Gen E. Jetzt Probefahrt buchen auf ford.de. Achtung, Achtung, hier kommt die gute Nachricht des Tages. Der Erdbeerkäse-Podcast ist weiterhin für dich da. Ob Eskalation im Sommerhaus oder Fremdscham bei den Bachelors, wir und Gäste wie Anja Rützel, Wanni schreibt, Jan Köppen oder Bachelor Nico Griesert schauen mit, lachen mit und leiden natürlich auch mit. Während andere dich für dein Guilty Pleasure Trash TV schief anschauen, sagen wir seit mittlerweile fünf Jahren Willkommen zu Hause. Und jetzt kommt's, auch in diesem Jahr sind wir wieder auf Tour durch ganz Deutschland und Österreich.
Also, wenn du dich gerade angesprochen fühlst, checke gerne erdbeerkäsepodcast.de für die Termine und Tickets.
Guter Geschenktipp übrigens für alle Trash-TV-Fans im Freundeskreis oder halt die, die es endlich mal werden sollten.
Wir kriegen sie alle. Also Erdbeerkäse, der Trash-TV-Podcast, überall wo es Podcasts gibt und dieses Jahr übrigens auch auf grosser Tour, bestimmt auch in deiner Nähe, erdbeerkäsepodcast.de.